welcome to this video a new part of the
chest giant series I wasn't entirely
sure where to put this this game
fragment under which serious it also
could have been under the tactics and
calculation series because it's a purely
technical thing this disposition but I
felt that under this tactics and
calculation then I only should be
positioned that are really yeah in a way
that they should be able to be treated
as a puzzle to be solved by you while
you serve while you watch the video and
this is not the case form for this
position where it's basically impossible
to get to grips what would happen with
them what is happening because it's
frankly some mind-boggling yeah I
recently saw the position it's a
fragment of an L occurring game elack on
against a person called Hofmeister play
played in Petrograd 1917 from this game
and the only this position is known the
moves that led to the position are
unknown therefore we cannot say which
move it is so we only know the position
was on the board and it was probably in
yeah and an exhibition game simultaneous
display something like that it wasn't a
an official tournament and yeah but what
happens is simply simply beautiful let's
see what happened if we sum things up
black as a piece up for two points but
it's a total mess blacks King is also in
in some trouble you know the king is
stuck in the corner and white has the
Queen near the King right also has some
dangerous pawns however black has
definite counter play like Knight f1
check so it's a very dramatic situation
how should it be evaluated yeah it seems
that absolute best play like computer
style best play leads to yeah leads to
black being even better but it is very
very difficult
right now really has only one move to to
continue the battle and this is c5
played by Alec on yeah white wants to
get this a-tech going yeah use this
Bishop and get to the black King yeah
black now has a ton of options very very
difficult to to assess I can tell you
what the black player played he went
with the move be fire b5 as it turned
out was a mistake but let's now check
the alternatives we will look at the
game and the beautiful continuation
later what the possibilities were there
there was one
chitra Knight f1 check this at first
looks like a perpetual King F 193
however this is not the case
y can avoid the perpetual by taking him
that looks crazy at first but it has a
clear point after Queen takes White has
the fantastic move C takes b6 and all of
a sudden White is winning it takes a few
moments to really understand what's
going on the rook can take here and the
Queen is hanging yeah let's start with
the queen capture if the Queen captures
there's rook take c8 check and then j7
it isn't this great white is getting
everything back in first this check then
I have Queen and at the end White has an
extra pawn bishop f2 no it's four
against three and white has very decent
winning chances probably he will win
yeah that was the first wide right if
black takes here
there's just Queen takes d8 yeah and
after this
white is just winning let's say
routinely there is nothing special
require T the pawns are too dangerous
yeah Knight f1 check the first very
obvious move is failing now we can now
look at other moves Knight e4 also looks
very tempting with Queen check here
maybe and also attacking the Queen
however White has a great reply she
takes b6 again sacrificing the Queen
yeah how does it continue
if black now would take the Queen then
White was relatively easily was b7 yeah
it's also beautiful made by the way
check checkmate and amid you don't even
need the rook on b3 for that so very
cute so the Queen cannot be taken yeah
and the rookie is hanging there on c8
and again this is check leading to a mid
so a great great situation black can
only hang on for a while with the crazy
move Queen takes G to check and that the
big point it needs to be a check now
King takes as rook takes to see to check
so why it must take with the rook Knight
takes here and now why does indeed
surprisingly in good shape
a5 is a month or b7 ism's we can't you
get b7 from status after that Knight
takes is played
JB rook takes and again we start to
approach a normal material situation and
maybe Ruby to a rook g7 and the game
just continues however maybe more
interesting even is after rook takes
Knight takes the move a5 which just keep
this the situation going white is
playing with the piece down
but he has a fantastic attack going the
ideas that after f5 we go rogue G to be
to where we threaten to play b7 Black
has a very tough time to defend against
this white might be even winning him
it's very very difficult
however oh this is a relatively moot
point because black has some even
veterans of this position he can play
look to be too this is by far by far the
strongest now the idea now is to again
play Knight everyone check and mate on
g2 in this case so why this serve is
forced to trade there is nothing else
yeah and now it's already clear that
white is in dire straits Queen g3 is a
big threat and lots of the attacking
potential now has has been traded with
rookie to White's best try is probably
come in d7 attacking the rook here but
black can save the day with Queen e5
check King edge one and then Queen c7
back which keeps everything under
control okay sorry for the little noise
this was my kitchen timer
okay Queen c7 and blacks black game is
holding the fort still looks dangerous
but I think he has everything under
control something like that for example
leads nowhere from white so Luke e2 was
the way to go but all this is of course
exceptionally difficult yeah I mean this
is a total mess of a position black went
b5 and b5 is as weird as it sounds
a losing move white now wins the game by
absolutely beautiful plane yeah Ella
can't took on b5
and now black plays Knight to reform we
need to check the movie night everyone
check off yes this looks a very very
attractive at first but after King to h1
of course
Nigeria white again has a nice it must
be rook takes g3 of course otherwise
it's a draw yeah now after this green
takes g3 White has the fantastic
resource b6 yeah take a moment to to
just just just look at the position
white is threatening b7 here black can
exchange Queens even here that's the
amazing thing if like a trades Queens
white takes here and believe it or not
white is winning in this position black
has absolutely no defense here after
rook takes e2 there is T take c7 Bishop
takes it 7-piece and check King b8 and
Bishop h2j
rooks e7 and now black is in a deadly
pin white can now simply March the king
up and gobble up pawns can go all the
way to his six if you want black is
basically staying mated he has
absolutely no way out of this pin
amazing simply amazing
yeah and what else is there what should
like - if you take on b6 well I just
recapture the Queen takes d6 why does
the whole set of pieces down but yeah he
gets everything back with this Mucha at
the end check check
and at the end White has a winning
endgame you know he can even play g4 in
this position
because here later the h-bomb is
decisive an amazing amazing sequence of
moves
so black couldn't get a perpetual
chicken what else is there
does he have something else rupee -
maybe now almost white can take and play
b6 again yeah and white wins with this
advanced pawns this is one of the one of
the less spectacular lines so what what
did you do we played Knight reform yeah
how does right continue you probably
already says suspect the the answer to
that because the motifs am repeating
itself now white wins with b6 yeah
fantastic let's check let's check the
the various lines black took on d6 here
but alternatively he could have taken on
b6 which after C takes me yeah really
everything's hanging but there is simply
no defense if black here for example
takes on d6 we get check checkmate
this made again now here black can try
some desperado check check here just to
get the look of the C file but at the
end share is always b7 check check check
check that the end white we'll check
when a bishop yeah it's non-believable
amount of of great lines him like in the
game after b6 he took on d6 after which
white can simply recapture white is a
whole three down but the advancing pawns
and I just
just kidding black it's like an
avalanche of pawns great simply great
stuff yeah black now played the
crazy-looking new fluke e to c7 I know
it looks strange but what what else is
there this is what he played yeah what
else is there yeah you can try to take
but again be saving and this is the
winner
check with white getting to checkmate
Luke take c2 is therefore easily refuted
group b8 chandi of this made again check
check checkmate I made yeah it takes b6
maybe check but white can afford to just
take care his attack is still
unstoppable
for example chapter Queen e5 King edge
one Queen d7 white wins with this
capture and screen takes check Bishop
takes is a totally winning King and pawn
endgame
yeah and the end black decided to play
play this move
maybe Bishop c7 or something to check
wait I forgot this line Bishop c7 can be
can be tried here wide wins with
perception King b8 and now he takes c7
check check rook takes
rook takes yeah I need to check my
variations twice you can it's so easily
make a mistake and if you if you have
looked at it before
King h1 yeah now black has no defense
anymore after rook takes a I have this
coming and after Quinn takes Bishop h2
wins the house yeah King takes again
Bishop h2 yeah very very nice in the
initial position here after the X takes
as mentioned black played rookie to c7
yeah and now White has a winning a
winning sequence b7 check check King to
b8 and now the final stroke the
fantastic d7
this is just an amazing position isn't
this great
those pawns on d7 and b7 yeah black
tried this chat the last move and after
the simple answer King edge one resigned
black has no way to avoid made by means
of the CAPTCHA on c8 yeah it's
absolutely no way out for example to win
takes we take we take check one of those
here checkmate and it's a maid yeah like
I really am cannot cannot do much yeah
you can again do some sort of desperado
business but after this and white can
simply take them and end win like this
yeah an amazing amazing game fragrant
where you sometimes think that okay
really they played
this is not a study yeah it's it seems
that they really really played this
played this game yeah and if there is
something doctored there and changed
afterwards it's so too beautiful not to
show some more fantastic sequence of
course black could could have played
Ruby too and gotten the better chances
but we can be glad that he didn't he
went with b5 and then we got this
fantastic fantastic finale to this game
yeah I hope you enjoyed this it's a it's
a fantastic technical game and then
sequence thanks for watching